oh uh oh that's a good question
hypothetically I would go gay for oh you
worded it differently me identify a
straight I am a straight man my name is
Alaska and I'm a straight man Oh would I
go gay for Daniel Craig Mr Bond himself
got the you know the Peck ledge which is
pretty nice the accent is just an
immediate sell kylo Ren or Adam driver
because of those curly locks and that
schnoz I would go full-on gay for Justin
Bieber he turned his life around and
that's a really attractive trait to me
he's just so smooth and beautiful
there's only one hunky man that reigns
true in my heart and that has to be
Dwayne the rock Johnson of course is the
sex appeal it's the muscles the good
looks the acting prowess and the rock
bottom's
I want to know the frailty behind the
muscles that's the biggest thing before
we get into it he'd be like just holding
his arm like this and like it's okay
Rock and I'll grab his big muscular arm
over well I know Justin loves to skate
so I'd take him to a skate park you know
maybe he'd buy me a Slurpee we could
hang out
probably like an East Asian like art
museum I would think then get boba if
he's not in a boba though like that's an
automatic like that's that's a
deal-breaker since he's got the whole
bond thing going I kind of expect him to
take me out on a date there'd be like an
element of danger and then we'd escape
and then you know cuddle the rock fans
call themselves rock climbers so I'm
just saying they better move the hell
out the way some climbing that mountain
is it too late now to say [ __ ] me I want
to sing that to you Justin